so you're going to need to update the
save profile method in the conference
API class so that see here where we get
the profile every time we get the
profile we'd create a new one instead of
doing that what you need to do is check
if the profiles already in the datastore
if it is get it out if it isn't create a
new one and then set the values were
passed in by the form for the values
that the form doesn't pass in for new
entity use the default values and if the
entity already existed then leave the
existing values in the properties you're
also going to need to add a method in
the profile class called update profile
that takes a display name and the
t-shirt size and updates them if they
haven't changed that is if they aren't
now